I think I have a missionary Zeal to
bring culture closer to young people
being exposed to culture theater novels
films makes us better thinkers and helps
us understand the problems of our world
my name is Fatima nakfi and I'm a
professor of German and film studies I
am interested in the way we move and
build space and how that builds space
influences us and my new project is on
hospitals I started becoming interested
in hospitals as they were being built in
the 1880s in the austro-hungarian Empire
and at that time Austria-Hungary was the
epicenter of modern medicine they're
thinking about every aspect ventilation
what kind of Windows what kind of paint
do you use on the walls where the late
20th century is very much about all the
stuff that's underground the hallways
that are endless the bureaucracy that
has to be navigated I was very
interested in looking at the way in
which artists reflected on those
architectural advances
I start with people like Arthur
schnitzler and Lorena Maria I moved
through the 20th century by authors like
Thomas Bernhardt and then I actually
look at filmmakers in the 21st century
who work on this interface of
documentary and fiction there's a
fantastic documentary by Nicolas
gayahaita about one of these large
hospitals that has been recently built
in Vienna he starts us off in the
basement where these robots are
transporting dirty laundry and the
refuse that's left over at the end of
the day watching this film you realize
that there's so much of it that happens
behind closed doors and underground this
whole machine Hospital complex to which
we're not really privy but which
determines our experience once we're in
those walls it shows us a world where
there's no daylight and it leads also to
reflect upon what it might mean for
health and Recovery to be in these
completely artificial spaces a lot of
films started to deal with this in light
of Europe's aging population and we saw
it with the pandemic we were bombarded
with images of people in icus these last
few years have shown us how hospitals
are a very fraught topic for us what
does it mean for the end of our lives
that we spend these in institutional
settings where we are very cut off from
the outside
most of my work arises out of
conversations with people the wonderful
thing about Yale is that the colleagues
are so willing to listen to each other
throw ideas around to be very open and
very curious and the Yale School of
architectures here people there have
helped me think about space in a new way
as I then encounter particular works of
art books that I'm reading films that
I'm viewing some of them start to speak
in a new way then and I want to dig
deeper and that usually does entail
going to the archives looking at
manuscripts storyboards to see what kind
of notes are there and the margins what
things tell us beyond the printed page
or the completed project I am hoping to
make people more aware of their material
surroundings to think more profoundly
about what kind of spaces we are
creating for ourselves for our children
for the future
whether you're looking at a building or
a film or a billboard everything around
us in human culture can be read and
interpreted and I think that we have to
return to them over and over again to be
able to finally really see them and
understand them that it's not something
that you can do with a quick glance
[Music]